I want to win self-driving cars yeah
we're running it on the phone I could
build a better vision system test the
autopilot myself in three months Moog
was going to lose because there's no
market for $100,000 system for us we're
just gonna push the software up there
and then BOOM
all these cars level-4 self-driving we
got the insurance company to underwrite
the policy you don't have to pay
attention anymore at 17 George Hotz
became one of the world's most famous
hackers when he was the first person to
break into the iPhone and reconfigure it
to be compatible with non AT&T providers
he was also the first to jailbreak the
PlayStation 3 allowing people to plain
on Sony games and use unapproved
software but where's Apple co-founder
Steve Wozniak sent him a letter of
congratulations
Sony sued him Potts known online as Geo
ha quickly became a cause celeb of so
called hacktivist groups including
anonymous and LulzSec they attacked
Sony's network despite hot C's protests
igniting a firestorm of legal and media
scrutiny this case is about a lot more
than what I did and me it's about
whether whether you really own that
device that you purchased
now this twenty eight-year-old technical
wunderkind is up against way Moe Tesla
uber and most of the auto industry in
the race to build the first fully
operational self-driving vehicle he's
taking an approach drastically different
than his well financed competition I
don't belong in Silicon Valley
I don't his company , AI is trying to
bring plug-and-play driverless
technology to the masses and is doing so
with 3.1 million dollars in seed money
commas dozen member team which works out
of a house in San Francisco has built
technology that takes over the existing
radar and drive-by-wire systems and
modern cars incorporates a smartphone's
camera and processor and then makes the
car drive itself where the Android
self-driving cars right
think about Tesla's the iOS all these
other manufacturers are hopelessly
clueless when it comes to self-driving
how do we build something that just
works on their cars right and so the
idea is that you would then be able to
plug and play your self-driving system
in pretty much any production car you
need some tailoring to the car but so
what we're trying to do is you take the
top 20 cars
America and that's like 50% of the cars
sold we want to support most of those
how does your system work in contrast to
other systems that use sort of a lot of
expensive sensors like lidar you have to
have a lot of equipment you're just
tapping into the car's existing
capabilities right we ship a camera and
we use the radar that's built into the
car and we use the sensors that are
already in the car yeah those systems
are just not shippable they're not
feasible for passenger cars because
there's no market for an $100,000 it's
just a money sink right so you know this
is just done by people who do not think
about the feasibility of anything that's
why we use cheap sensors gotcha thousand
dollars mm and you think that that's
sufficient to be able to accomplish
everything that the other self-driving
companies are doing with their lidar
systems oh absolutely right so the truth
is even with those lidar systems nobody
is act as a level four there are six
levels of self-driving ability today's
offerings such as Tesla's autopilot and
, a eyes open pilot max out at a level
two which means the car can auto drive
but the driver constantly needs to pay
attention and be ready to take over the
holy grail is level four at which point
the car can handle all driving on most
roads the steering wheel and pedals can
be removed and the human becomes a
passenger who can read nap or take in
the landscape in order for you know that
to be oak hold your system better be
good bit better than humans not perfect
it's never ever gonna be perfect but you
know it's got to be better than humans
right and no system is there Adam so
before you started common AI which is
your current company you gave an
infamous interview to a Bloomberg
reporter where you took the reporter on
a ride in the self-driving car that you
had worked on for a month and you just
got to work that morning good
are you crazy or how did you how did you
know that you weren't gonna die when you
brought that out onto the road it's the
same safety model that we have today the
safety works like this is twofold one
the second you touch either the gas or
the brakes the system just stops doing
anything right so you always have that
that user override but the other one
that you even need more than this you
need to make sure that the car is never
going to do anything so quickly that you
can't respond and the way you deal this
with this is torque limits no it's never
gonna go like that it can't it can't
there's hard limits preventing that and
actually I didn't even write them I'm
using the hard limits that were built
into the car gotcha so so the car has
it's sort of own built-in system where
the power steering which is mostly
electric now not hydraulic will not be
able to jerk it in front of a truckers
in the exact commas first consumer
product is an app called shiver which
turns your phone into a dashcam and uses
its GPS and accelerometer now the
company is launching panda an
open-source $88.00 dongle that plugs
into your car links it to your phone and
puts out fine grain detail about every
aspect of your drive so you can actually
use a panda as the bridge between open
pilots which is the software that will
drive your car in the car itself panda
is a universal car interface so when
it's used by schiffer it's read-only but
when it's used by open pilot it's
connected over USB and I can actually
touch the car okay so that's what tasks
you into the the car system so you can
move the steering wheel what kind of
cars like can I use this on my 89 Volvo
or like do I need a prefer for shipper
you'll get something from every car
manufactured after 1996 now if you want
to get the fancy self-driving stuff well
there's only a few cars that open pilots
ports right now we're gonna start
getting a lot more like I said I want
you know in 2018 I want to support the
majority of the top 20 car sold in
America and right now is there like a
baseline of cars that have you know
drive-by-wire break by wire gas by wire
that you can tap into yeah so we support
its Hondas and Acuras right now we just
bought a Toyota Prius we're gonna be
doing all the Toyotas this year a user
one of our users has ported it to the
Chevy Volt we have a bounty program I'm
just because he cleans up the code a
little bit we're jiz it in we're gonna
pay him out ten thousand dollars we have
a bounty up for the Ford Fusion for
somebody to do that or go down to the
Tesla Model S B&B your life
we're gonna support them all gotcha so
you're kind of hacking into the
carmaker's systems essentially in order
wouldn't think about it like that you're
certainly not hacking into anybody's
systems your car right we're not not
hacking you're not like changing the
firmware you're not jailbreaking your
every car has a different API to get to
the steering wheel the gas on the brakes
um so you know it's about finding the
api's in the new cars but the car makers
they don't want you to be able to have
access to our car manufacturers sell
cars all right what do they care yeah so
why don't why don't you just call up
Chevy and be like hey can I get access
to the vote why do you pay $10,000
bounty let's even say they wanted us to
get access to it right not opposed to it
I think they probably would rather us do
with the knockers at the end of the day
you sell more Chevy's all right but you
know they gotta go through their lawyers
and you're talking to the business
development guy and then he oh he's a
level-five he can't be in the meeting
with the level fours and they're just
such bureaucratic organizations that
it'll take me less time to reverse
engineer it than it will to get legal
approval and then once you finally do
get legal approval oh you can be sure
it's coming with a 10-page contract that
says you can do this and that's not this
and definitely not that don't even think
about that will sue you liquidated
damages and I'm not playing with that
we're gonna reverse engineer it we're
gonna make it open okay so you're asking
for forgiveness not permission basically
I'm not even asking for forgiveness
right I'm just not like there's no
permission to be asked yes your car I
don't need permission to you know to use
my things that I buy however I want
right maybe I think a lot of people
should get out of this mindset of
thinking right never always said this
would like the jail breaks and stuff get
out of the idea that like you know no
you're buying the PlayStation 3 and it's
a closed box and actually Sony owns it
and you don't no no I stopped thinking
like that right so you've described
Panda is basically like a Fitbit for
your car you get all this information
all this data coming from your car about
the driving and the driver but you're
you're also feeding this information
that you crowdsource because you you
have all these different people who are
voluntarily putting this software in
their car and you're feeding that into
an AI which then is learning how to
drive so how do you think that this
approach is is different and why is it
better than what way mo is doing what
you know Tesla is doing these sort of
bigger players
Tesla understands more about what we're
doing but let's look at way more right
so way low when they want to figure out
how to build a cell for
ancar they sit for engineers down in a
room and they talk about okay well we
come upon a stop sign we know that we
should stop and we know that we should
stop this distance and wait could you
get the other DMV handbook out let me
see you okay we have to signal 50 meter
that's not what driving is right this is
the same failure of computer vision for
many many years right when people wanted
to build like a detector to see if there
was a chair in an image they would write
out the definition of a chair they would
say okay well a chair has a back and it
has four legs and it has weight what
about a barstool is that a chair well I
don't know we're gonna investigate
barstools there's a lot of people
thinking about this problem and it's
absurd you want to figure out if there's
a chair in an image or not you get a
million images of the chairs a million
images of that chairs and you use
machine learning to train a classifier
that says chair or no chair right so
that's the same approach we take to
driving there is no rigid specification
or definition of driving driving is just
what people do when they drive and in
order to really get access to the full
diverse spectrum of what driving is you
need a huge crowd source database and I
mean that's what we're building and
we'll just learn what it means to drive
from people who actually drive hmm right
because you got you know operate with
humans right it's some it's some like
it's some leftist utopian fantasy oh
we're gonna wipe the roads of of all the
cars and we're just gonna have electric
cars interactive look at a Google
commercial if you want to see this all
right um it's not what's gonna happen
right what's actually gonna happen is
it's gonna be a bunch of self-driving
cars bunch human operated cars and they
all gotta interoperate right right and
the humans ain't changing to match the
self-driving spec so you're saying that
one advantage that you have is that
you're not using Google engineers and
Google cars and everything to go out
there you're actually looking at what
real people are doing in the field I
don't think about what driving is I say
so show me what driving is all right
that's that's more expensive than if
they want to add a new driver you can
add pretty much limitless people who
have pandas we have a huge network of
thousands of people on our network and
then the other advantage is that they're
they're taking like a rule-based
approach so like you're saying they're
defining a chair rather than letting the
computer figure out what a chair is yeah
but don't they also use AI and sort of
deep learning techniques what's the
difference in well no they're systems so
I mean everybody is moving towards AI
and deep learning right and like
obviously Google is going to you know
get to level four before we will nobody
doubts this right but the reason Google
is
to lose is they're gonna get to level
four within $100,000 system right and
then they have a whole thing to go
through to deal with you know okay how
do we actually get this in the hands of
people if we solve if we get the AI
problem solved a year after Google
Google's still gonna be sitting there
fingering it okay well you know maybe we
could all finance it to people for us
we're just gonna push the software
update right I'm gonna push the button
and be like anyone knows this too right
we're just gonna push the button in
there boom all these cars are level four
self-driving we got the insurance
company to underwrite the policy you
don't have to pay attention anymore done
all right and that's the coming out plan
right Google can only you know iterate
and build on top of what other companies
have already done was chrome the first
web browser no but it was the best right
which was Android the first non iOS you
know operating system for smartphones no
but it was way better than like Symbian
a BlackBerry OS right but but it's not
Google in some ways is not like an
innovative company right and then when
they try to innovate you get things like
Google glass the Google self-driving car
project is like Google glass I say
Google is the Xerox PARC of the
self-driving car industry there you see
all these good ideas you're bringing out
all your companies right push another
button and the information is sent
electronically to similar units around
the corner or around the world this is
an experimental office system it's in
use now at the Xerox Research Center in
Palo Alto California soon Xerox systems
like this will help you manage your most
precious resource information they just
grabbed grab defeat from the greatest
victory in the computer industry Xerox
could have owned the entire computer
industry today so in this analogy you
would be sort of like the Steve Jobs
going into the Xerox campus getting the
graphical user interface and everything
like that seeing that they're messing it
all I'm a lot more like the Bill Gates
maybe he wants the Steve Jobs Bill Gates
Wow nobody ever wants to be the Bill
Gates I'm not an Apple kind of company
I'm a lot more like a Microsoft kind of
company what do you mean by that they
practically or more art than technology
right now they do have good technology
backing it up but for me the end result
is technology technology is the only
thing in history that has had this
compounding effect on on human wealth
we live in houses there there they're
heated we have lights this is off all
technology right and that's what I want
to be a part of a lot more than well art
and so you don't care about making
things beautiful no yeah I don't care
what make things beautiful I don't care
about I'm very anti advertising right
like the idea of advertising like we're
almost gonna let you know manipulate
people into buying our product and you
have like atrocious companies like
Facebook you know Facebook you're not a
user of Facebook your Facebook's product
Facebook sells your attention to
advertisers right Facebook uses you
Facebook uses you right like like that's
how it works you know it's not even in
Soviet Russia it's and uh Palo Alto
California a little park right yeah no I
never wanna be that kind of company
right like we build technology and you
know we open source as much as we can as
well hmm
right because you know it's not about
here's the pie I want my slice to be
bigger it's about we can build a really
big pie let's build mmm so Apple just
recently announced that they are sort of
scrapping their yeah hardware initiative
and they're just going software does
that worry you
no um so again when you think about
Apple as a company they're gonna play a
lot more in the Tesla arena what about
that other 70% right hmm most smart
phones in the world are androids most
self-driving cars in the world in five
years will become AI so you basically
want everybody who's watching this to be
able to turn their car into itself
Dressler in five years yeah it really
emphasized no regressions well you know
we're gonna work to make this better and
better and better and more and more
consumer friendly right this is all you
need to drive a car yeah clap , a eyes
first attempt at consumer hardware was
the comma one a full self-driving kit
for under a thousand dollars
but Hots awarded the product launch
after getting a letter from the National
Highway Traffic Safety Administration
detailing safety concerns and regulatory
compliance issues Hots true outrage both
from those who saw the event as a
government overreach and those who
thought the government had valid
concerns and instead of addressing them
Hots was just picking up his ball and
going home when you look at what we
actually did right not what the media
said we did so you know maybe we didn't
release the actual $999 comma one on
kickstarter but we released all the
plans for you to build pretty much
exactly what the comma one was
for free and you can hold him for way
less than $1,000 and self-driving car
the car could certainly drive itself so
the thing about the comma one was it was
never gonna be a mass-market product we
were maybe gonna sell a thousand of
those to car enthusiasts um so you know
let's even say we're making making
foreign dollars profit unit that's
$400,000 right profit to come AI that's
more than the lawsuit would cost me more
right so it just didn't make economical
sense for us to continue with the comma
one is planned we had to think of a more
clever way to avoid a lawsuit but still
basically achieve the same outcome and
that's why we open sourced it you want
to start a company in the self-driving
space literally rip us off literally
please its MIT licensed just download
our stuff build it into your cars don't
give me anything you know you look at
the world like that you realize
open-source is the way to go hmm you
know so what are the benefits to you of
open sourcing all of your plans and your
products we can eventually work up to a
consumer product and we can kind of let
the market figure out like if we don't
build the best localiser if somebody
else built and open-source localizer
we'll use that coming as an ecosystem
we're gonna be the constellation of you
know things surrounding Android just as
androids an ecosystem right it's Google
it's the app developers it's the phone
manufacturers with a Google for the
ecosystem but I want to see the
Samsung's in the HTC is enough all right
Camas new self-driving kit for under a
grand is called the common neo hot says
it's similar to a gear virtual reality
headset and that it's powered by a
smartphone the common neo mount schools
and connects the phone to the car comas
open pilot software then taps into the
phone's camera and the car systems to
auto drive it and there are people out
there who have these and they're
actually posting on you there's ninety
nine people right now running open pilot
we have thousands on the shipper Network
will see 10x growth in the next year
we'll have a thousand right where we're
constantly growing right now I'm not
sure how many cars away Moe has running
so they might be the second largest
network but I think we're pretty close
when they're Tesla obviously has tens of
thousands of these things right and so
the common neo is a sort of a full
self-driving system maybe someday I
probably shouldn't say this but like
maybe someday all you're gonna need a
shipper and Panda right you learn the
shipper app on the phone it talks to
your car with Panda maybe just your
phones
to drive your car right right now you
needed a special phone well right now
you need a special phone running a
special operating system you know you
need a cooling solution because phones
aren't quite at that point yet but every
year they get better and every year
billions of dollars is poured into
making smartphones better and we get to
leverage that billions of dollars of
investment of companies in a way that
like you know no other self-driving
company would even think oh they're
running it on a phone yeah yeah we're
running it on a phone phones are really
really good yeah it's super exciting
when you think about like really what's
possible here and the fact that almost
nothing can stop it and that's why it's
open source or it's not even like like
you don't have to like work with us you
don't have to sign some sketchy back
room business development deal it is
open source and MIT licensed please
download it and use it all right like
it's not like you know we're not one
company what initiative you're gonna
gonna issue it it can't you recall right
like what do you recall we didn't sell
you anything get a recall software yeah
good luck oh right
so you mentioned Elon Musk release the
Titan so we've been able to accelerate
autopilot and bring it to market faster
every car coming off the line and test
at the factory has the autopilot
hardware you guys got into a little bit
of a public spat I guess maybe it wasn't
that negative but in 2015 you kind of
criticized some of his technology as his
technology I criticize his choice of a
partner in mobile life okay yes you
criticize the fact that he reneged on a
contract well this is what I want to ask
you about because you guys have kind of
different stories about this so my store
is correct so he says you wanted to bet
that you could outperform his system
Yeah right and then you made this bet
and then you ultimately didn't want to
agree to the bell mosque needs a vision
system for his car
I wanted to replace mobile I I don't
like yeah sure I'll do it give me a
recon tracked and I'll get you something
incredible you know you want change deal
last minute he changed it from a
contract which has rigid completion
criteria to basically an option for him
to buy he's kind of like build it and
then you know I'll pay you if I like it
well it's not worth it for me right at
the time he said in an interview that
you were under estimating the technical
challenges involved right and he said
quote it's not like George Hotz a one
guy in three months problem you know
it's more like
thousands of people for two years well
it's it's two years later right who's
closer who's who's gonna make this
happen my chest was always gonna be a
little bit ahead of us um because they
started earlier right all I said was I
could build a better vision system than
Mobil I myself in three months and like
you know I kind of did that right so
yeah the whole self-driving problem no
of course that's going to be a I'm not
gonna say thousand-person problem coming
I was a 12-person company it's been
about two years and I think it's gonna
be at least another three in order to
fully solve the problem I've come to
respect a lot more what he said there
about you know start a company you need
validation you need good engineering
practices he's right mmm fine yeah I
mean you know at the end of the day uh
you know the egomaniac a big ego I love
I love I love being right but not at the
expense of being wrong right
misunderstanding you know you should
never you should never I tribute to
malice what you can attribute to a
misunderstanding and I have a ton of
respect for your mosque I mean I really
do it's nothing there's nothing like how
I feel about Ford in Florida zone Elon
is doing so much good for the world when
it comes down to it I really do regret
if I inconvenienced him I mean you know
you punched me I'm gonna punch back a
little but like you know at the end of
the day Tesla's not our competition we
would love to see Tesla succeed I would
personally just love to see Tesla's
basic succeed because that's the kind of
world I want to live in the oh it turns
back to the pie argument right
I'd rather Elon Musk have a much bigger
share of the pie than me as long as the
pie tastes awesome right for it on the
other hand like those companies need to
lose right because what good are you
doing for the world you're holding the
world back to make money right this is
you know a big big fan of capitalism but
like you got to avoid rent-seeking all
right you got our void rent-seeking and
in a monopolistic behavior and where
you're just making money because you
have kind of yeah yeah
Elon is doing doing absolutely great
things for the world and if his capital
was better deployed somewhere else
besides paying me then I think you made
the right price so you also bet him last
year that your system could successfully
navigate the Golden Gate Bridge okay we
can both time the media so I'd like to
play it up so we can both drive across
the Golden Gate Bridge
okay after an intervention let's just
say so you both win
when everyone with big pie you know it
doesn't win for I have to say though I
also really like your pie analogies
because I'm also from New Jersey so yeah
last thing about Elon Musk yeah I he's
he's become sort of an alarmist about AI
he wants international bodies regulated
he thinks it's gonna destroy humanity if
we don't do this it is the biggest risk
that we face as a civilization is
artificial intelligence once there is
awareness it will be extremely afraid
what do you think of that I'm not sure
it presents any particular threat that
previous weapons have not it's just
about how the people are gonna use the
technology now if Elon Musk is calling
for an international arms control
regulation he should look at history and
see how all that has worked so you're
skeptical of sort of intervening you
think it'll be it'll self-regulate or
people in the field are better I think
that I think that yeah you know listen
to people in the field I certainly think
that it's incredibly premature to talk
about any sort of government level AI
regulation that's not it's not going to
kill me tomorrow there's things there
are a lot more likely to kill me
tomorrow all right like a driving yeah
yeah yeah the AI alarmism I mean these
aren't problems that we should be
thinking about but to believe that
somehow in the next two years Google is
going to accidentally build Skynet is
absurd you're not an alarmist about AI
in that sense but you have you know
raised a few eyebrows because you've
said in the past that you think that AI
is going to take everybody's job
absolutely and you cannot wait for that
day you think this is a good thing right
but people have been saying that since
you know before the Industrial
Revolution right the elevator operators
were saying that like the elevators
gonna take all the jobs so what's what's
different now so the Industrial
Revolution replaced man's muscles right
very few jobs today at least in first
world countries are people doing work
with their muscles right you even think
of like traditionally muscular work like
mining it's not people with pickaxes
it's people with levers operating
hydraulic machines right so you know
people are always at always gonna
replace all the jobs right the car
really did replace all the jobs of the
horses right
aren't that many horses left the horse
population of the world peaked in 1917
the last refuges man's mind and once you
start building minds that are superhuman
well you know yeah there are no more
jobs for humans it's great this is a
great world wait isn't this tea isn't
this the end game of technology in
general right didn't you sit there and
be like man you know I'm really sick of
ho in this field wouldn't there be great
if there was a mechanized oh right then
you got to sit on it and operate it and
now you go to a modern farm and it's
gotta know it's a tractor with an apple
an X GPS I think like you know maybe
some union is why the person still has
to sit there but they just don't do that
much I they watch the finger I've enough
and I mean this is a great world right
this is this is a great world so comma
will ultimately be a mechanized hoe
company as we work where our talents are
so what does a world like that look like
where nobody has a job except for a Iran
I think I think a month in advance I
think I think I got I got a I got a date
tomorrow night I'm excited about that
that's about as far in the future as I
think but I really don't you maybe wanna
get some Camel I think that would be
really cool right like you know to
replace throughout everything today but
yeah I wanted a today are you just less
but you don't see this as a dystopian
future you're hopeful absolutely yeah
not a complete optimist about the future
people just outraged about things I
don't know why well living in the best
time ever
right we are living in paradise
practically yeah when's the last time
you have to deal with home man when I go
to the coffee shop there might be Lions
Lions right so getting back a little bit
to the driving so that the data that
you're collecting you know it's about
things like people's locations their
driving habits you know a lot of
personally identifiable potentially
information things that would be
attractive to stalkers hackers pee eyes
government agencies so you know being
being a super hacker yourself you know
that these things are vulnerable to
outside groups command so how are you
protecting your customers data and how
do you view that the privacy issues so
first off let's talk about personally
identifiable information from from
shipper right we do not record either
the microphone or the phone facing
camera I don't want pictures of your
face I don't want to make a name I don't
rage I don't wanna get gender all right
this is not your data that I'm
interested in this is your cars data
that I'm interested in I'm not trying to
sell your advertisers right every night
so I take your point but I would say at
the same time that's the the art the NSA
makes a similar you know argument all
the time right we're not listening to
your phone calls we're not looking at
your Facebook profile
we just have metadata but if you look at
somebody's metadata you know you can
find out where they work they have kids
where they go to school where they go to
church what the religion is I just make
the data public right I would have no
problem with the NSA and metadata
collection I don't think these things
are necessarily bad I just don't like
the idea that one organization has an
op-ed let's make the data more public so
you just don't value privacy as like
sort of a you know in your own life like
would you be upset if privacy went away
there's a thing about privacy in general
right and at the end of the day you know
people might yell at me for this but
this is really how you have to look at
the world right the NSA is a big problem
and the reason the NSA has a big problem
because they have privacy and you do not
be nice if we both had privacy but I
don't see that happening either so maybe
the real solution is we don't have
privacy right but they don't have
privacy either that's a pretty radical
view right like I don't think there's a
lot of people who'd be very comfortable
with all of their data being online
there's a difference between all of your
data and all of your metadata right
right now like you know data in terms of
like we're gonna what you're saying on a
phone call maybe even if you make a
phone call but like where you drive I
mean that's already public and we have
to accept this I could hire a PI to
follow you around right and that doesn't
really violate any expectation of
privacy I think when you step out of
your home into the world you're you're
entering a public space this is what the
laws say well I mean Google did it all
with Street View right and if you're
outraged about Street View come on
Google spends all this money to do this
and then provides a free service for
everybody I love Street View right
so you got to think about whether the
you know the benefits just outweigh the
costs I don't want to have a monopoly on
data right this is the old way of
thinking what if we could open our data
up more and really think about it not as
like you know Facebook owns this data
Google owns this data but we all
collectively own the data right and
you're contributing to a big collective
pool of data right no it's at the market
it's not you know it's not like oh we're
all gonna do this for smiles and roses
or you know whatever
UNICEF create this data contribute to
this all the data combined is a whole
lot more powerful than any piece of the
data alone and I think we can do
incredible things with these sort of
data sets right what regulatory issues
do you see having to tackle as you kind
of move forward into a semi self-driving
or a full self-driving system well I'm
even seen this Nestor's the regime be a
lot better than the last initiative
regime they the mark whatever his last
name was the first mission he talked
about like how his dad died in a
motorcycle accident how this is a
personal crusade for him and how if
Tesla autopilot has two more accidents
were pulling it off the road
stop stop 30,000 people are dying a year
stop with that rhetoric right let's use
statistics let's use math let's use
engineering and let's solve these
problems right you're not gonna be able
to constructively prove this is what you
do with a stop sign the arguments that
should be made for these sort of things
and they're the kind of arguments the
Tesla's making are statistical arguments
okay if it turns out that people with
the system get into 50 percent less
accidents than people without the system
the system is good so is what you're
saying that you're you're arguing for
outcome based versus process based
regulation are they actually adopting
that sort of standard yeah they do they
do in fact the nishta tesla auto pilot
letter which came out after the comma
one was very encouraging for it this is
basically witnessed two sad Tesla said
here's our crash statistics before auto
pilot here's our crash statistics after
and you know at least like rear-ending
collisions were reduced by 30 percent as
they should be right so this is it's a
great thing to see that Nishat accepted
that argument did almost be criminal if
you were to ignore or a technology
that's saving tens of thousands of lives
just to just anything that can can work
how come based should be what's right
and dude identify as anything
politically no you just are highly
tribal no interest it's all about the
war with nature sort of like an Adam
Smith state of nature okay some day so I
can eventually move into virtual reality
and live in a great artificial world
that everything is awesome in and then
go on cool quests everyday and slay
dragon beast some virtual dragon beast
you know no real dragon beast have to
die even vegans are okay with this
guys stop fighting like at the bottom of
your web page you have the text we are
actually about to change the world that
mostly is a stab at other startups who
use this rhetoric of we're going to
change the world right yeah I mean you
know Facebook's changing the world too
yeah you know hey yeah Hitler change the
world though you know hey it's not it's
not always right like we're we're
changing the world we're not like using
this to sell you any timers so you're
serious about it you're supposed to what
it's about like yeah it's again it's
again it's about like like I think of
the world is like nature and we're
trying to build like like you know more
accurate local geysers and then better
sensors and put more data on the
Internet and grow the internet and like
that kind of stuff right so that's what
I mean by actually not you know I've a
line in a song with the SoundCloud
sounds like that Kon flash Tom Cruise um
changing the world is just a euphemism
for how can I get you to give more stuff
to me and I think that's how a lot of
people view it and here's my argument
for this right I have the best phone I
have the best phone you can buy in order
to get a better phone I would have to
spend millions and millions of millions
of dollars I know what a practically
start a phone company right because you
can't buy a better phone than this right
there isn't like a phone for two
thousand dollars that's any better so we
have to move the world forward in order
to get this technology that I want I
can't sit in my basement and build my
own virtual reality thing we need all
the technologies that support that we
need to move the whole ecosystem further
you know we need a better display
technology we need better localization
technology for head-tracking maybe we
should start looking into like
neurological link stuff so I can feel
sensations right like it's a huge it's a
bio it's it's the biggest project maybe
humanities ever done take it oh maybe I
is the biggest one and then a I can
build me all those cool things and as
this what open access is contributing to
that sort of communal knowledge
gathering who's open access like even
Tesla has gone to open access for their
patents and some of their technology
your open access oh yeah intellectual
property here's my feeling intellectual
property right it's kind of like we had
this problem of like good scarcity right
a lot of wars are fought over good
scarcity and like how many potatoes are
there I got to kill you because I need
more potato we build this intellectual
property thing that's actually not
scarce right you know I feel property
a scarce good I think we put artificial
squeeze guns to make it artificially
scares really people really this is the
best thing we could come up with right
um so ya know I'm all about like just
you know which I think we shouldn't
really view it as like a monopoly on oh
okay I drew Mickey Mouse fur so Mickey
Mouse is mine you can't make Mickey
Mouse porn definitely not definitely not
Lobby to make sure right come on so you
want the pie to be big enough that
Mickey Mouse porn is it you could be in
a small sliver maybe not a corner of the
pie that I go to but hey you know that
is the first example you thought of that
that's the classic one I mean you think
about you think of the Sonny Bono
copyright extension Act you think about
these copyright extension acts that have
been passed copyright is designed to
incentivize the creation of work right
why do you need to extend it to cover
works that have already been seven years
it's it's become absurd right and then
like patents or this this absurd like
it's not you know they're just no big
companies fighting each other maybe it's
monopolistic maybe it's not it's not
you're protecting your inventor anymore
right it's big companies we need a
patent strategy and all right let's wrap
up here so your first goal is to get
your software good enough where it's at
a level three system as as you've said
so where the driver can fully disengage
and doesn't isn't expected to have their
hands over the wheel the whole time
right for certain stretches of road at
least like maybe if you're in traffic or
if you're on the highway yeah how far
away are we from this so our hardware
isn't quite good enough to do that now
so we're gonna need like the next
generation of kamma hardware which we're
looking at and we're trying to be like
the phone companies we're trying to come
out with something new every year right
moire eye tech is gonna need to be
better and then we're gonna have to
operate this thing in shadow mode for a
while all right where people are using
it but they still have to pay attention
then if it turns out that all these
people paying attention actually didn't
need to have paid attention by
statistical arguments then we'll show
these statistical arguments to an
insurance company or to a bank or you
know insurance is pretty simple game and
then we say okay on these stretches of
highway your system is level three
feel free to disengage you need to be
ready to take over 50 seconds so your
pitch to the insurance company is hey
statistically our system is safer than
if you let the driver drive themselves
so
you should want them to and how long do
you think it'll be before if you had to
give a guess
before that'll that'll come online um I
think in some stretches of Rome maybe
two years um and then you see like the
full battle you know three you start
getting more and then five I think the
self-driving car game is gonna kind of
be over and you're gonna see who the
winners are all right so in five years
I'll come back and see you and I won't
have to drive myself probably all right
well I'm counting on you to make this
happen yeah I'm really excited about it
but I'm just watching so yeah I might be
wrong you know I'm always humble in the
face of nature um so we'll see we'll see
you but I'm gonna try my best
George Hotz of kamma AI thank you so
much for talking to us today
for reason I'm Justin Monticello
[Music]